[Música]
a
escala en parís fraude o moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español la enfermedad de alzheimer
sigue siendo uno de los principales
desafíos de nuestra sociedad pese a
haber sido descubierta en 1906 es decir
hace ya más de un siglo sigue hoy sin
encontrarse una solución un medicamento
que permita contrarrestar este
padecimiento esta enfermedad más grave
aún se estima que de aquí al 2050 el
número de casos de personas afectadas
por algún nivel de demencia se
incrementará en más de un 50 por ciento
para hablar de este tema de los desafíos
que esta enfermedad plantea de qué
perspectivas se abren hoy en día en
términos de investigación y solución al
alzhéimer saludamos aquí en nuestro
estudio a la profesora dulce puppy
garcía directora del centro de
investigación rico biología regeneración
y reparación de tejidos de la
universidad de parís cretéil mejor
conocida como la opec especialista en
glee co biología de la degeneración
neuronal doctora bienvenida a esta
escala en parís profesora bienvenida
muchas gracias blanca antes que todo
dulce y garcía yo quisiera señalar que
el pasado mes de mayo el senado francés
en el marco de la semana de américa
latina- le otorgó usted las palmas del
senado francés el reconocimiento por su
trabajo precisamente en términos de la
enfermedad que nos ocupa hoy alzheimer
que representa para usted este tipo de
reconocimiento del gobierno y del senado
francés una responsabilidad sobre todo
en el dominio del alzheimer y no
únicamente también en las relaciones con
la américa latina con méxico un
incentivo de trabajo no únicamente para
mí pero para todo el equipo
que es la fuerza que se necesita para
combatir este tipo de desafíos
el equipo de con el que trabajo un
reconocimiento sin duda alguna muy
merecido profesor a más de un siglo
después señalábamos hoy en día todavía
no existe un medicamento un remedio a
esta enfermedad que afecta cada vez más
y más amplios sectores de la población
en todo el mundo exactamente la
enfermedad de alzheimer es fue descrita
en 1906 como usted lo comentó
las primeras observaciones que se
hicieron fue descrita por acumular dos
tipos de proteínas en el cerebro del
paciente
un tipo una proteína
lo voy a resumir es la proteína beta
péptidos a beta que se acumulan en la
matriz extracelular fuera de las células
en el cerebro del paciente y otra
proteína es la proteína tau que se
acumula dentro de las células neuronales
del paciente
la terapia actual
en el dominio del alzhéimer
usa como blancos terapéuticos estas dos
proteínas y usted puede imaginar que
habiendo sido descritas hace más de 100
años y habiendo sido el objeto de una
investigación
enorme
muchos esfuerzos
como no se ha podido
curar como no se puede modificar es
importantísimo que escuchemos lo que
estos fallos terapéuticos nos están
diciendo
es esa
tenemos que entender lo que está pasando
en las células neuronales porque están
muriendo la enfermedad de alzheimer es
una es un trastorno neurológico que
termina por matar las células neuronales
y tenemos que entender esto es muy
importante de profesora dulce para ti
garcía porque estudios realizados
recientemente demuestran que la mayor
parte de la población y nosotros
incluidos conocemos muy poco o casi nada
de esta enfermedad pero al mismo tiempo
1 de cada 4 personas que han sido
encuestadas dicen que son problemas de
mala suerte
no es un problema de mala suerte puede
considerarse porque la enfermedad de
alzheimer es un trastorno muy complejo
dada su complejidad es multifactorial
hay diferentes genes diferentes factores
de riesgo
una persona puede imaginar que es un
mala suerte haber caído en tal número de
factores de riesgo que lo llevan a la
enfermedad pero pero yo no estoy muy de
acuerdo con con el hecho de la mala
suerte porque
todo tiene una explicación y la
enfermedad de alzheimer debe de
entenderse para que deje de considerarse
como una mala suerte
es un
rompecabezas y este rompecabezas
si usted lo tira y cómo se acomodan las
piezas puede ser la suerte mejor no
verlo así mejor verlo como un desafío
para entender cómo acomodamos las piezas
y como uniendo las podemos ver el
mecanismo
no sé si responde a su pregunta en
complemento de esto dulce para apilar si
hay otra cuestión que es importante
también destacar la enfermedad de
alzheimer se asocia generalmente a la
vejez es correcto esto la principal el
principal riesgo el principal factor de
riesgo de la enfermedad de alzheimer es
la edad si se asocia a la vejez
efectivamente
es normal la patología comienza mucho
más temprano comienza muy muy muy
[Música]
posiblemente durante la juventud pero se
va a manifestar en la vejez porque las
acumulaciones de proteínas de las que le
comentaba al principio son acumulaciones
que empiezan desde desde edades muy
tempranas pero hasta que llegan a un
cierto nivel de acumulación
la enfermedad se va a manifestar
entonces usted puede imaginar que las
proteínas empiezan a acumularse desde
desde el nacimiento posiblemente para
acá brack que es una anatomopatología
alemán estudio una gran población de
cerebros hizo un gran estudio y encontró
que la acumulación de la proteína todo
el interior de las células neuronales ya
existía a los 17 años
pero no tenemos enfermos alzhéimer a los
17 años de julio pero las
características ya están ahí
se va a manifestar a los 60 70 a 80 a 90
años
porque se necesita tiempo para llegar a
acumular para llegar a acumular una
cantidad de proteína patológica antes de
que se manifieste entonces por eso es un
factor de riesgo profesora usted hablaba
hace un instante de uno de los factores
daba un ejemplo que me parece
interesante que es esta imagen de un
rompecabezas o sea nuestro cerebro sería
una especie de rompecabezas estos
elementos perturbadores que usted dice
que son múltiples van a generar
precisamente la enfermedad de alzheimer
qué quiere decir desajustan
completamente el rompecabezas usted
trabaja notablemente en un tema que son
los azúcares explíquenos de la manera
más sencilla posible precisamente ese
rompecabezas cómo se puede desajustar
con esos azúcares que perturban al
rompecabezas sí
efectivamente
[Música]
los azúcares son azúcares complejos no
estamos hablando ni de glucosa ni de
fructosa ni de los azúcares que están
implicados por ejemplo la diabetes es
otra cosa estoy hablando de azúcares
complejos que se encuentran en la
superficie de células son moléculas muy
largas muy largas que son capaces de
interaccionar con varias proteínas al
mismo tiempo y estructuran en la
superficie de la célula estructuran una
organización de proteínas
y estas proteínas están relacionadas con
los factores de riesgo de la enfermedad
de alzheimer el rompecabezas
lo manifiesto así porque son el
alzhéimer es multifactorial
una pieza del rompecabezas puede ser la
manera de alimentarse el ejercicio la
actividad neuronal las relaciones
sociales digamos que es 20 por ciento de
piezas del rompecabezas y 80 por ciento
de piezas del rompecabezas van a
representar son 80 piezas entonces usted
puede ver van a representar a los
factores de riesgo genético del
alzheimer el alzheimer tiene únicamente
el alzheimer familiar está relacionado
con tres proteínas cuando hay mutación
hay enfermedad si olvidamos en
estas tres proteínas que son
responsables de 1 % de 12 por ciento de
de los casos de alzheimer en el mundo 98
el otro 98% pueden ser considerados como
factores de riesgo quiere decir que son
segmentos de adn en donde hay
modificaciones y hay accidentes
y los desajustes
y estos este adn se va a traducir en rn
que es también un concepto muy muy muy
de moda
y en la red de nevado va a dar una
proteína entonces nos imaginamos esta
pieza con varias proteínas que cada una
está estudiada por grupos de
investigación muy poderosos en el mundo
cómo unirlas las azúcares con los
azúcares complejos es una pieza central
del rompecabezas no es la pieza central
pero es una pieza central muy difícil de
estudiar que necesita una gran se
necesitan especialistas y no hay muchos
especialistas en el mundo somos muy
pocos pero este este tipo de azúcares
por ser largos y por ser complejos
pueden interaccionar con las diferentes
piezas y unirlas
y unirlas y al unirlas
comprendemos mejor la enfermedad en este
propósito y hablando de comprensión
usted hacía referencia a lo que decíamos
en esto fue descubierto fue descrito en
1906 hace más de un siglo una de las
razones que explicaría el retraso que
existe en esto es porque la gente que
estudia todavía alzheimer lo hace basada
en lo que se conoció hace ya más de un
siglo le falta actualización podríamos
decir comentaba usted lo de la rn
notablemente con el descubrimiento de la
vacuna por ejemplo contra el apoyo 19
con este nuevo mecanismo de rené ácido
ribonucleico permitiría precisamente que
esto podemos imaginar que a futuro en un
futuro cercano se descubra finalmente
algo que contrarreste nos vas a suprimir
pero que desacelere contrarreste la
aparición de alzheimer si
efectivamente la estrategia de rn para
generar anticuerpos que son generados
por la persona la estrategia terapéutica
con anticuerpos se ha utilizado mucho en
alzhéimer
fuera de los tratamientos sintomáticos
como el donde posible que son
anticolinérgicos que es lo más utilizado
ahora en el mundo creo que es enorme el
mercado de los anticolinérgicos
que no modifican en lo absoluto la
evolución de la patología
los anticuerpos
la terapia inmunológica efectivamente
puede ser de interés pero en el
alzhéimer
ha habido muchos fallos terapéuticos hay
conciencia del significado del desafío
que esto plantea para nuestra sociedad
hoy en día leía que por ejemplo de cada
dos estudios que se realizan hoy en día
sobre el cáncer hay uno sobre la
demencia ni siquiera sobre alzhéimer
exactamente
el alzheimer
se necesita poner fuerzas en esta
patología se necesita darle más apoyo
es parte de las diez grandes patologías
que afectan a la humanidad y es la única
que hoy no se puede curar confiamos que
en un corto plazo podamos finalmente
encontrar una solución a esto y tanto
mejor que haya expertos especialistas
como usted que se ocupan de ello
llegamos ya al final de este escala en
parís no me queda sino agradecer a la
profesora dulce papi garcía directora
del centro de investigación agrícola
biología regeneración y reparación
tejidos de la universidad de parís
decreta la apec su presencia en nuestros
estudios especialista de microbiología
de la degeneración neuronal gracias por
haber estado con nosotros ya ustedes les
damos una nueva cita aquí la próxima
semana en otra escala en parís
[Música]
[Aplausos]